Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Surfshark
VPN, más sobre esto en un momento.
La Antártida, ubicada en el área más austral
del planeta tierra, es un gigantesco desierto
de hielo de 13,66 millones km². Esto supone
que es un 35% más grande que todo el continente
europeo.
Hablamos de la última región en ser descubierta
y colonizada por el ser humano.
Y aunque hoy en día, en plena era de la información
tenemos todo tipo de datos al alcance de la
mano, es cierto que más allá del hielo,
las focas y los pingüinos, es muy poco lo
que en general sabemos del gran continente
blanco.
Y, ojo, porque esta región fría, seca, ventosa
y despoblada contiene aproximadamente el 90%
del hielo de la Tierra, y con ello el 70%
de todo el agua dulce. Y por supuesto, también
hablamos de muchos recursos naturales de todo
tipo.
Así que, a pesar de que la Antártida no
cuenta con una población originaria - como
sí la tiene el Ártico - arrastra varias
décadas de importantes controversias e intereses
políticos y militares que pueden terminar
provocando serias disputas en un futuro no
tan leja.
Así que la pregunta es…. ¿Estamos cerca
de adentrarnos en la era de los conflictos
antárticos? ¿Quien aspira a controlar este
vasto territorio y qué pretende con ello?
¿Qué riquezas ocultas se esconden detrás
de toda esta historia?
[Y antes de verlo una pregunta importante:
¿eres de los que te conectas a wifis públicas?
¿o te gusta siempre buscar el mejor precio?
Pues atento porque Surfshark es para ti.
Si eres fan de las cafeterías, los viajes
o llevas una vida nómada, Surfshark te mantendrá
a salvo incluso en redes wifi públicas cifrando
tus datos en línea y manteniéndote a salvo.
De hecho, el tema de la ciberseguridad es
algo que se toman muy en serio, siendo la
primera VPN comercial que puede presumir de
tener servidores en más de 100 países distintos.
Y, ¿sabías que muchas webs te muestran precios
según tu ubicación o dispositivo? Encendiendo
tu VPN de Surfshark conseguirás las mejores
ofertas al comprar por ejemplo tu próximo
billete de avión.
Pero por si todo esto fuera poco, con una
misma cuenta podrás registrar TODOS los dispositivos
que quieras sin límite: tu teléfono, tablet,
la SmartTV, el portátil.
Y esperad porque ahora viene lo mejor de todo:
ahora mismo usando el código “POLITIK”
acabado en “K” podréis disfrutar de un
83% de descuento y 3 meses gratis.
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos con nuestro video
de hoy!]
Queridos amigos, amigas, la Antártida es
un desierto de hielo, escasamente habitado
pero que sin embargo ha despertado un gran
interés entre científicos y exploradores
desde hace ya varios siglos. Poco a poco las
diferentes expediciones han ido incrementando
nuestro conocimiento sobre la zona…. Lo
que automáticamente despertó también la
ambición de muchos países para controlar
el territorio.
En la actualidad son 7 los países que reclaman
tener derechos soberanos sobre parte de la
Antártida, lo que ha creado todo un enjambre
legal y político cuyo fondo permanece sin
resolver.
La pregunta es: ¿Quienes son estos países
y qué persiguen exactamente? ¿Por qué tanto
interés por un territorio helado?
Pues bien, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver, pero
antes esta es una de esas ocasiones en las
que tenemos que empezar viendo un poco
de historia.
T1 (DE LA CIENCIA A LA AMBICIÓN POLÍTICA)
Desde al menos el siglo XV podemos encontrar
en diversos mapas un área continental denominada
“Terra Australis”. Un área cuyos detalles
eran completamente desconocidos y que se ubicaba
sistemáticamente al sur del estrecho de Magallanes,
es decir, al sur de Sudamérica.
Está última región, de hecho, sería la
primera en tener un contacto político-territorial
relevante con este territorio virgen.
Incluso, en 1539, la corona española nombró
a Pedro Sancho de la Hoz como Gobernador de
la “Terra Australis”. Esta fue la primera
vez que una potencia tuvo la pretensión de
apropiarse y gobernar la zona… Al menos
sobre el papel, porque lo cierto es que esto
no se tradujo en la construcción de bases
ni en intentos de ocupar permanentemente el
territorio.
De hecho, el área continuó sin despertar
mucho interés hasta que a finales del siglo
XIX y hasta principios de la década de los
años 20 se produjo la conocida como “edad
heróica de la exploración de la Antártida.
(En 1898 una expedición liderada por el belga
Adrien Gerlache de Gomery y compuesta fundamentalmente
por científicos y exploradores polacos, rumanos
y noruegos, se convirtió en el primer contingente
humano en pasar un invierno en este continente
helado. A partir de entonces y hasta la Primera
Guerra Mundial se pusieron en marcha dieciséis
expediciones de ocho países diferentes, todas
ellas con banderas compartidas entre diferentes
nacionalidades.)
Sin embargo, la historia dio un vuelco hacía
1903, cuando la Expedición Antártica Nacional
Escocesa estableció un observatorio meteorológico
en las islas Orcadas del Sur, denominado “Omond
House”, después de que su barco quedara
aprisionado por los hielos del mar antártico.
Cuando lograron volver a navegar, se dirigieron
a Buenos Aires para aprovisionarse; allí
cambiaron de planes, le ofrecieron al gobierno
argentino la venta de Omond House. La base,
el instrumental y los aparatos de observación.
El entonces presidente, Julio Argentino Roca,
aceptó por decreto el ofrecimiento y autorizó
a la Oficina Meteorológica Argentina a hacerse
cargo de la estación, que desde ese momento
pasaría a conocerse como Base Orcadas.
Años después, diferentes países fueron
asimismo desplegando bases en la zona y sumando
nuevas reclamaciones territoriales hasta crear
un enorme jaleo de paralelos y latitudes que
en muchas ocasiones, tal y como veremos, se
superponen.
Así que dicho esto la pregunta es muy clara…
¿Quién demonios controla la Antártida?
T2 (TIERRA DE TODOS… O DE NADIE)
La situación política de la Antártida resulta
muy particular… Es única en el mundo. Digamos
que ha formado una especie de condominio donde
algunos países reclaman una porción de soberanía,
al tiempo que otros, sin pretensiones territoriales,
mantienen bases permanentes o temporales de
investigación científica.
Por lo general, son las naciones más cercanas
a la Antártida, las que más empeño tienen
en extender su soberanía en la zona. Aquí
el concepto de proximidad territorial juega
un papel clave.
En concreto esta que veis en pantalla es una
lista con los países que mantienen alguna
reclamación territorial sobre la Antártida.
Y luego tenemos otros tantos con bases permanentes:
entre ellos, por supuesto Estados Unidos,
Rusia y China, por citar solo algunos ejemplos.
En total, se estima que ya son más de 70
las bases permanentes en este territorio.
(TABLA 1: RECLAMACIÓN TERRITORIAL SOBRE LA
ANTÁRTIDA.)
(De esta lista, Francia y Noruega justifican
sus reclamaciones en base a los descubrimientos
q ue misiones con su bandera hicieron en la
Antártida. Nueva Zelanda y Australia, al
ser naciones australes, justifican cierta
cercanía geográfica.
Sin embargo, todo se pone mucho más interesante
y complejo cuando echamos un vistazo a la
situación de Reino Unido, Chile y Argentina.
Como podéis ver, estos 3 países tienen reclamaciones
de soberanía sobre territorios superpuestos.
Es decir, los británicos reclaman casi la
misma porción de tierra que Chile y Argentina.)
Eso sí, en cierta forma todo este caos de
soberanías y todas las misiones científicas
están en cierta forma organizadas por la
comunidad internacional.
En 1959 12 países firmaron en Washington
el Tratado Antártico, un acuerdo que hoy
engloba a 54 países.
En este documento se establecieron cuáles
serían las bases fundamentales para gestionar
la zona. La idea era reducir cualquier posibilidad
de que la Antártida terminará provocando
un conflicto a gran escala.
Básicamente estos son los 3 puntos claves
del acuerdo que hoy dictan cómo se gestiona
la Antártida. Son los límites legales en
este inhóspito territorio:
(“Reconociendo que es en interés de toda
la humanidad que la Antártida continúe utilizándose
siempre exclusivamente para fines pacíficos
y que no llegue a ser escenario u objeto de
discordia internacional (...) las naciones
firmantes han acordado lo siguiente:
Art. 1: Se prohíbe, entre otras, toda medida
de carácter militar, tal como el establecimiento
de bases y fortificaciones militares;
Art. 3: Libertad de investigación científica
y cooperación hacia dicho fin.
Art. 4: Ninguna actividad que se realice mientras
esté en vigencia el tratado servirá para
hacer valer, crear, apoyar o negar un fundamento
de reclamación de soberanía territorial.”)
Y eso no es todo. Este tratado también se
ha ido reforzando con el paso del tiempo y
desde la firma del conocido como Protocolo
de Madrid de 1991 se prohíbe expresamente
la explotación comercial de los recursos
minerales que se puedan encontrar.
La idea es que la Antártida se convierta
en una reserva científica y natural con carácter
internacional..
Y de hecho, desde 1961 se celebra periódicamente
la Reunión Consultiva del Tratado Antártico,
una especie de foro para tomar decisiones
sobre el lugar.
Además, desde el año 2003, también funciona
en Buenos Aires la Secretaría del Tratado
Antártico; un órgano ejecutivo encargado
de facilitar el intercambio de información
entre las Partes del Tratado y promover los
protocolos medioambientales que tienen que
respetarse en las incursiones que se hacen
en la zona.
[Sería algo así como una especie de gobierno
antártico.]
Y así es como este continente helado funciona
como una especie de tierra de todos y de nadie
al mismo tiempo.
Pero… Vaale, vale, Ya sé lo que estáis
pensado… Entonces, ¿Por qué demonios hablamos
de ello en VisualPolitik? No parece mucho
más que un parque natural protegido.
Pues… la cuestión queridos amigos, amigas,
es que no todo es de color de rosa, empezando
porque Chile, Argentina y Reino Unido comparten
prácticamente la misma reclamación territorial.
Y, decidme, ¿Se os ocurre algún ingrediente
mejor para el conflicto?
Pues… ¡Atentos!
T3 (¿UNA NUEVA “GUERRA FRÍA” ANTÁRTICA?)
Tratado Antártico, Sistema del Tratado, Secretaría
del Tratado, sÍ, de momento todo parece muy
bien armado y diseñado para que la Antártida
sea un zona de cooperación y convivencia
mutua.
Pero esto no siempre ha sido así:
(Entre 1946 y 1947, Estados Unidos impulsó
la Operación Highjump, la cual consistía
en el despliegue de 13 barcos, 4700 hombres
y numerosas aeronaves en una incursión antártica.
El objetivo era llevar a cabo maniobras y
ejercicios para entrenar al personal y probar
el material bélico en condiciones de frío
extremo, pensando, claro está, en un potencial
conflicto con la entonces Unión Soviética,
)
Años más tarde, en febrero de 1952, tuvo
lugar el incidente de la bahía Esperanza,.
En este caso uniformados argentinos desplegados
en un destacamento naval al norte de la Antártida,
emitieron disparos de advertencia a militares
británicos que se encontraban desembarcando
materiales frente al área manejada por Argentina.
(Luego, apenas un año después, en 1953,
se repitió un episodio similar con el incidente
de la isla Decepción. 5 Royal Marines británicos
desembarcaron y apresaron a dos marinos argentinos,
como respuesta a la construcción de un refugio
argentino en la zona.)
En otras palabras, que la cosa se estaba poniendo
cada vez más tensa.
Eso sí la firma del Tratado antártico mejoró
considerablemente la estabilidad de la zona,
pero entonces la Guerra de Malvinas agitó
de nuevo este asunto, ya que el despliegue
territorial que Londres sostiene sobre el
continente blanco tiene base, precisamente,
en Puerto Stanley, la capital de las Malvinas.
La presencia de Reino Unido en la Antártida
se despliega desde las Islas Malvinas, por
lo que el enfrentamiento con Argentina afecta
automáticamente al continente blanco. Digamos
que Buenos Aires considera la propia reclamación
británica sobre la Antártida como un acto
colonial cuyo origen está en la no descolonización
de las Malvinas.
Claro que quizás el enfrentamiento que más
puede llegar a desarrollarse con el paso del
tiempo es precisamente a los dos países sudamericanos
presentes en toda esta historia: Chile y la
Argentina.
T4 (SIN NINGUNA CONFIANZA)
Es algo poco conocido, pero en 1977 Chile
y Argentina estuvieron al borde de entrar
en guerra por el Canal Beagle, un paso marítimo
que conecta al océano Atlántico con el océano
Pacífico y que es reclamado por ambos países.
Ese año, la junta militar argentina decidió
hacer caso omiso de un laudo arbitral britanico
que establecía los límites de la zona. En
su lugar movilizó a las Fuerzas Armadas.
El propio Juan Pablo II tuvo que intervenir
para persuadir tanto a Videla como a Pinochet
de que el uso de la fuerza no era una alternativa.
Y aunque hoy esa posibilidad parezca descabellada
lo cierto es que Buenos Aires, Santiago y
Londres protagonizan un trío de tensión
constante en el extremo austral de América
del Sur.
Un enfrentamiento político y diplomático
que en los últimos años nos ha dejado capítulos
de esta historia como estos:
N1 (Octubre 2007: Argentina lista para desafiar
los reclamos antárticos de Gran Bretaña.
El ministro de Relaciones Exteriores de Argentina
advirtió [..] que su país solicitará la
soberanía sobre el fondo del océano alrededor
de las Islas Malvinas y la Antártida. The
Guardian)
N2 (Diciembre 2012: Argentina enojada por
territorio antártico que lleva el nombre
de la Reina. BBC)
N3 (Septiembre 2021: Argentina y Chile chocan
por una disputa marítima en el extremo sur
americano. El Gobierno de Buenos Aires acusa
a su par andino de apropiarse de 5.500 kilómetros
cuadrados de su plataforma marina en una de
las zonas más australes del planeta. El País)
N4 (Octubre de 2022: Generó malestar en Chile
la visita de tres ministros argentinos a la
Antártida. La tensión se produce luego del
fortalecimiento de los controles de vigilancia
en el Atlántico Sur por parte del gobierno
argentino, mediante la creación del Comando
Conjunto Marítimo. La Nación)
A ver, esto es quizás lo más importante
de toda esta historia. Más allá de la pura
política, los 3 países colaboran en materia
de rescates o de investigaciones científicas.
Es decir que las cosas fluyen razonablemente
bien. ¿Pero qué pasaría si el continente
blaco dejara de ser tan “aburrido”?
Porque… Veámoslo de otra forma… La Antártida
es un continente inmenso cubierto de hielo.
Pero debajo de ese hielo, queridos amigos,
puede haber muchas cosas. Y también en el
fondo del océano.
De entrada la Antártida es la mayor reserva
de agua dulce de todo el mundo. Hablamos del
70% de todas las reservas mundiales.
Además, sus cielos están casi totalmente
libres de interferencias de radio, por lo
que son potencialmente ideales para la investigación
del espacio profundo y el seguimiento satelital,
y por tanto, para operaciones de vigilancia,
espionaje y control de armamento a control
remoto.
Además, un estudio del Servicio Geológico
de EE.UU. en 1992, concluyó que podrían
existir grandes cantidades de petróleo y
gas natural. En una primera aproximación
muy incipiente se apuntaba a más de 19 mil
millones de barriles de crudo y 106 trillones
de pies cúbicos de gas. Es decir, que si
esas son las primeras indagaciones la realidad
podría ser mucho más lucrativa.
Y de hecho en los últimos años algunas estimaciones
apuntan a que podríamos estar hablando de
más de 200 mil millones de barriles convencionales.
Es decir, que la Antártida podría contener
las reservas de petróleo más grandes del
planeta.
Y exactamente lo mismo ocurre con muchos otros
minerales. La Antártida puede ser una enorme
fuente de recursos… Completamente virgen
y abierta para el primero que pase por allí.
Por supuesto, el Tratado Antártico que antes
hemos visto prohíbe la explotación comercial
de recursos naturales en esta zona del mundo…
Pero algunos creen que solo lo hace hasta
el año 2048. Hay debate al respecto.
Sea como sea, hoy por hoy los costes de extracción
serían disparatadamente altos, sin ir más
lejos por la enorme capa de hielo que cubre
el continente.
Pero, ¿podría cambiar esto en el futuro?
Sobre la tecnología caben pocas dudas…
La política ya es otra cosa…. Pero el 2048
no está lejos…
¿Tendrá esta noticia algo que ver con todo
esto?
N5 (El régimen chino aumenta la presión
para construir una base naval estratégica
en Tierra del Fuego. China quiere que el sur
argentino sea su “puerta de entrada” a
la Antártida. InfoBae)
Seguro que en un futuro, de una forma u otra,
este continente blanco nos dará mucho de
qué hablar.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Sabías que tantos países reclaman su soberanía
sobre la Antártida? ¿Cuál crees que será
el rol de Argentina, Chile y Reino Unido en
la región? ¿Crees que pueden producirse
futuros conflictos políticos, económicos
e, incluso, militares?
Dejadnos por aquí abajo vuestros comentarios
y abramos debate.
¡Importante! Recordad que con el código
“POLITIK” acabado en “K” podréis
disfrutar de un 83% de descuento y 3 meses
gratis de Surfshark. El link, como siempre,
en la descripción.
Y ahora, si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias una vez más por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.